listen up everyone is going to die
oh not these people no no no no don't
worry I mean sure one day they will die
we all will but the point is they all
need the gentle art of Swedish death
cleaning what is Swedish death cleaning
you say basically cleaning out your
craft so that others don't have to do it
when you're gone if you can keep track
of your things you have too many
when I'm done in here You're Gonna Want
to entertain
it's about discovering what's important
to you you can't save
this is an inflatable wiener and also
this leader talk I'm getting hungry
but they are here to make our lives
better
gives you this kind of perspective this
sharpness I don't want to live this way
I need your help
my mom really wants me to have this but
you don't like it
let your home be a reflection of you the
toughest thing I ever had to do was tell
my kids their mother was dead going
through that cleaning has helped me
become a forward person life changes
thank you look at the screen
this is not a show about death it's
about life we say that death cleaning is
for Life yes it's about here and now I
guess we do have a legacy maybe everyone
does really I knew that you guys were
going to decluttering my house I didn't
know you were going to declutter my soul
[Music]